thank you
[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here you're a personal astrophysicist
and this is going to be a cosmic queries
Edition I don't know if you know the
history of this we we did it on a lark
uh some years ago because questions
would show up in our inbox and we said
why don't we sort of staple them
together and make an episode out of it
and it turned out to be very successful
our fan base loved it but then we got
like greedy about it and now you can
only ask questions officially if you are
a member of our patreon Network and so
and but you can do that at the lowest
entry level that we have which is like
five dollars a month I got with me my
co-host Pro Paul Mercurio Paul how you
doing man hello Neil great to be back
yeah great man yeah I think five dollars
a month everybody should be able to have
five dollars you know you should uh
unless you go into the track
the track still exists yeah that's five
dollars that's a cup of coffee at
Starbucks yeah I know that's right
that's all for a month right that's
right that's all that is and one less
coffee that's all well today we're we're
orbiting the solicited Cosmic queries
around the expertise of a friend and
colleague from across the pond Natalie
Starkey Natalie welcome back to start
talk oh thanks for having me it's always
good to join you guys we love the accent
we love the accent oh my God we love it
okay you can't help it
I don't feel that sophisticated right
now yeah yeah we just feel so inadequate
I know exactly
um so let me remind people of Natalie's
expertise so she as I said not only a
friend of Star Talk she's an ace science
communicator and she's a science media
producer at the Royal Society of
chemistry in Cambridge that would be
Cambridge England uh she's written two
books catching Stardust I love it and
Fire and Ice and that has a paperback
edition that's coming out very soon and
she wrote Our planetarium show here in
New York City at the American Museum of
Natural History and that show was called
worlds beyond Earth I see I've seen that
show and I remember saying to myself
there were flaws in this show
hang on a second what did you mean when
you said so this is the right moment for
this yes all right so Natalie remind us
what catching Stardust was about was
that the Stardust Mission uh well
remember correct it does feature within
it because my works are a little bit on
the Stardust Mission when I was doing
lab work
um but it focuses mostly on comets and
asteroids just in general so I look at
some of the missions that have been to
comets and then talk about sort of the
past the history of comets and asteroids
and also then going to the Future what
are we doing with them in the future how
are we going to divert them from
colliding with Earth or how we're going
to use them to mine them for precious
metals and things now you realize there
was a hit best-selling book and hit
movie on exactly this subject all right
there's been many books
but uh uh I think Michael crichton's
first novel was The Andromeda Strain oh
was it okay I think it was where there's
a piece of sort of space dust that we
captured and brought back to Earth
because wasn't the Stardust Mission we
brought Comet dust back to Earth
um yeah so Stardust yet that was the
first sample return Mission
yeah exactly so as any good science
fiction movie or story unfolds we go
into space and something bad happens
right that's the whole plot that's right
well it wouldn't really be much of a
movie to stay and watch it's like well
we went to space everybody was very
pleasant and they gave us tea and then
we analyzed the sample in the lab let's
catch up with what's in the lab and
nothing bad
so you didn't bring back any any killer
bugs I guess
no I mean but they did bring back amino
acids which is really cool so like what
a lot of people don't realize is that
comets and asteroids contain
um but basically the building blocks for
life and so actually they measured um
glycine which one is one of the amino
acids within the cometary samples that
were collected by Stardust and they
didn't know it at the time they were
worried it was actually contamination
that had been brought about from the
scientists handling the material but
then since then we've analyzed other
comets in space and and samples of
comets and we've seen it there again so
we know that actually the stuff that was
on the starter samples was was amino
acids in space which is really cool
um when you're thinking about life
elsewhere in the solar system so it's
it's I mean you you said it just
casually but it's a very big challenge
to make sure that we don't contaminate
the samples that we're analyzing yeah
and they say look there's DNA hey look
there's the rhinovirus
you know oh they're frogs
why don't you have your gloves on how
many how many times do I have to tell
you this I have a bunch of Kleenex you
know
can you stop sneezing the dust is making
me sneeze
yeah so that's a whole branch of NASA I
think uh they have a whole division
called planetary production where we
don't forward contaminate where we're
going to explore and we want to make
sure contamination doesn't come back to
earth precisely so yeah because if we
send a spacecraft up in space and we
want to land it on a planet or a moon or
a comet restaurant we don't want to then
take bugs from Earth and then put them
on that place and go look we found these
bugs here we need to know that that's
perfectly clean before we do that so
that's why we don't just go out and just
put things on different planets and
things and that would be relatively easy
to do but we need to make sure that
we're protecting where we're going and
equally the other way around we need to
make sure what we bring back doesn't end
up with Earth bugs on it and we don't
know where they've come from right so
I'm glad so that's at the risk at the
risk of a silly question so the amino
acids that were found I know they're
amino acids here because I hear about
them
are they different than the amino acids
that exist on Earth great question
really good question and actually
there's more Amino
acid space and we we have on Earth
there's more amino acids than we need
for Life as we know it so actually they
now we've been analyzing loads of
different meteorites which are just
pieces of space rock that have landed on
Earth and other samples from space we've
discovered a whole raft of amino acids
way more than we need so
um it might be that they're not all
needed for life but they just exist
anyway Natalie I think you're taking the
extra amino acids and making life forms
of your own well we maybe
and that's what we're yet to find out
but we know the potentials there you
know so in any of these moons or comets
maybe there's you know there are
different forms of life that we we don't
know at the moment so yeah it's there's
so much out there her neighbors are like
is it me or they're like six or seven
more people in Natalie's house than
yesterday
yeah and they're like there's like an
old man and a baby no there's someone
trying to crawl out of the basement you
know that's what
so how about
um there's another Point here this is a
little bit bit inside baseball but
Natalie that's an expression we use here
in America when you're about to give
detail that probably no one cares about
oh okay
any show called inside baseball and you
really have to be into baseball right
like just to watch it or come near it at
all so this is an inside baseball
question as I remember my biology uh
life on Earth has a handedness to it not
that you're right-handed or left hand
but the molecules twist in a way that
they could twist the other way but they
don't and if they did we couldn't use it
in our life forms anyway so on these
rocks or in the Stardust the comet dust
do you have both do you have half
twisting left and half twisting right so
this is the chirality isn't it
and I'll tell you what this is so bad
but I can't remember
um what they found but so basically if
you found that we left aren't we on
Earth I forgot yeah
here's my definite answer why the left
or right chirality I'm sure of it so I
can't remember and I I don't know
whether it's
important that you know if we had the
other handedness and whether we couldn't
have a parallel life in that handedness
or not um but I honestly I just cut my
brain has gone blank you're not having
looked at this it's my understanding
that we could but we just don't it's
just an observed fact yeah that
everything is in one way Paul do you
remember that that uh was it a potato
chip or something that that Frito-Lay
made where it was had all the oil of any
normal chips but you couldn't digest it
because I think the the molecule had a
different chirality to it it went
through you yes it went through you and
the warning on the on the back of the
package said
um may cause anal leakage exactly
your body has no idea what to do with it
even though it's oil right right so
thank God we're talking about something
I know now anal leakage so let me tell
you when I was a young lad
so I think I think it's there's a whole
fascinating sci-fi story waiting to be
written about whether you have
left-handed or right-handed chirality in
a life form because that means you
couldn't eat you could eat them but it
wouldn't be nourishing to you right okay
so you could find lettuce somewhere but
you'd be like this is lettuce is no good
to me um but yeah no I I think that's
another issue we have that we would need
to develop experiments put out in space
to actually be able to measure that so
it's one step actually measuring whether
you have amino acids and then it's
another step figuring out more
information about them so and we're sort
of in the first steps when we're going
out to look at planets and things and I
have a fast chirality story I'm pretty
sure this is true exactly the molecular
form of the flavor
or mint
okay I think it's spearmint
is the molecular form is identical to
Caraway except Caraway has the opposite
handedness and so when it intersects
your taste buds your taste buds will
spawn differently because of the
different handedness of them so mint and
Caraway are are chemically identical
which is very cool really cool yeah
let's get to some q a so Paul what do
you have for us did you collect these uh
I collected them myself I went through
them and uh there's some really great
questions and and we're going to start
with Christopher Stowe in Pennsylvania
is there a relationship between active
geology volcanism and a planet or Moon
having a magnetic field oh yeah that's a
great question so
um generally we think yes okay so we
think that a a body has to be active and
activity means that you need to have
heat within that body and that can
create
um basically liquid so we need a hot
Rocky core usually and that can could
create a liquid ocean underneath an icy
crust like we see through many moons
throughout the solar system and we need
that kind of activity and the movement
of material it doesn't have to be Rock
and water it can be other elements and
and we think that needs to actually be
there to create a magnetic field and so
we have seen magnetic fields all
throughout the solar system but they're
not that common and they're common on
like some of the bigger planets and a
cut I think just a couple of moons we've
detected
um these kind of magnetic fields but you
can't just have a liquid right I mean it
has to be uh it has to be conductive yes
we can definitely do that um ocean so
you're saying it's not just that you
have it's not just that the place is hot
is that there's a difference in
temperature between places within the
object so that things convect and move
yeah right yeah so it's not necessarily
boiling hot it's just warm enough that
you've insulated a crust and then you
can keep something warm enough that it's
liquid and it can move so there's heat
below and and things move around and
yeah okay and when it comes to
cryovolcanism doesn't it have to be a
mantle below this this there has to be
so in other words for that liquid to be
able to not freeze so that even though
you're on a super cold yeah listen to
Paul's showing off he knows because I
know he just looks so better
I looked up one word and I repeated it
like a hundred times you sound so
knowledgeable Batman does his homework
okay all right yeah so crave organism
and generally it's happening in places
that are icy because we're talking about
cryobing the ice part and the volcanism
is the movement of that material so
usually underneath an icy crust you've
got um a rocky core in the middle which
is warm and then this kind of salty
liquid ocean and it's from there that
you're pushing material out so it's that
that mantle as you call it on Earth our
mantle is made of rock and it's below a
rocky crust but in on these kind of icy
moons and the mantle is made of of water
or methane or ammonia or some other
solvent and and that becomes your your
mantle but it's just made of something
different I'd like that analogy because
it you're analogizing basically the
physics of what it's doing rather than
the the composition the material itself
that's very I love that and then there
was the pulls of the moons that allow
the movement of that Subterranean water
so that it's not yet doesn't turn to
solid as well right there's this sort of
movement that happens that happens in
means around these giant planets like
keep it in Saturn they are actually they
wouldn't just be hot if they were not
next to that Moon not next to that Big
Planet they need to be pulled by the
gravity of that planet as they go about
their orbit and it's that Rocky interior
that's pulled and pushed and squeezed
and the rock is grinding all against
other bits of rock and it by friction
heats up and then it creates that heat
that makes that mantle liquid and then
produces that activity so you know if IO
for example wasn't next to Jupiter it
wouldn't be um the most volcanically
active plant um object in the solar
system but I think what Paul was
referencing was if it was if it was only
IO and only Jupiter then it would
stabilize into just a tidally locked
orbit and then you know heat drivers but
we have other tugging forces that like
you said there's it's a it's a it's a
push and a pull and a tug and a a
everybody's trying to get a piece of the
action in response to that is a
deposition of heat yeah right yeah yeah
all right Paul give me more before I
break see if we can you got it um this
is Connor home firstly I loved Fire and
Ice you really make geology exciting oh
that's so good I like the way that
sounds just like we know it's not
exciting
well that is one of the problem people
think geology is really boring and then
they read
[Laughter]
in a typical volcano how how high is the
pressure build up and how is it measured
does this vary between Earth and space
volcanoes I like that but let's take a
quick break okay actually I I I I
cheated there because I knew we didn't
have time to answer it but we could
dangle the unanswered question before
the break so we're going to take a quick
break when we come back more with our
solar system expert Natalie Starkey when
StarTalk returns
we're back our talk Cosmic queries my
co-host Paul Mercurio all always good to
have you man thanks great time always
fun and a friend of Star Talk solar
system expert Natalie Starkey coming in
from the UK Natalie great to see you
again yeah good to be back Paul we
dangled a question there something about
what's the difference in the pressures
between like Earth volcanoes and space
volcanoes and that's a interesting fact
how and how is it measured so Natalie
how do we how should we think about
the under crust pressures that
ultimately just blow a gasket
yeah so actually it's really dependent
on the Vault the volcano you're looking
at even on Earth
um you get loads of different conditions
so you've got some volcanoes that um
will erupt at lower pressures and some
that are up to higher pressures so
generally what we're looking at is the
amount of gas that's contained within
the magma and if you go to for example
let's take mounts and Helens everyone's
heard of that big volcanic eruption that
exploded half the
um the national forest and that would
that had a lot of gas in the eruption
and it was there for at higher pressure
If you go to somewhere like Hawaii
um you're looking at Kilauea that's at
lower pressure it's got less dissolved
gas um within the magma what happens is
as that magma rises with all those
dissolved gases they start to expand as
as just the pressure of the crust and
decreases and that magma gets thrown
apart basically so that's what would
create a very explosive eruption but um
you've always got dissolved gases so
even in Kilauea where it's not very
explosive you're going to get quite High
pressures so it varies a lot now when we
go into space and you're basically then
it's very dependent on the individual
place that you've got if you've got a
smaller body or a big large planet we
tend to only see activity on the smaller
bodies um so we've seen them on Mars and
we've seen quite big volcanoes on Mars
and we've got loads of volcanoes on
Venus and which are actually still
active today we've recently discovered
that there's still activity today there
whereas the ones on Mars are dormant
obviously or dead yeah so we haven't
seen activity on Mars for you know quite
a while now billions of years I think
um it's possible that it could one day
have another eruption it's very very
unlikely but Venus on the other hand is
is continually erupting so it's really
really active probably much more active
than Earth and um those are individual
volcanoes again are going to be all at
different pressures um and it will just
be at a point when it will it'll erupt
but they'll probably be more similar to
what we see in Hawaii those volcanoes
okay so I have a task for Paul well I
want you to invent you know how we tap a
keg or we should figure out a way to tap
a volcano okay
so we can release the pressure so that
it doesn't blow its head okay okay and
and and level cities that are at their
base and another thing like with super
volcanoes you know if they can release a
little bit of pressure along the way
with a little eruption then um it takes
the the pressure off that big one
happening so when they say oh there's a
Yellowstone eruption due it's due but
you know it has little eruptions and
releases bits of pressure along the way
so it just kind of extends that timeline
to when that big one's going to happen
maybe that big one never happens because
it just along the way releases a bit of
pressure so maybe we should purposefully
dig holes yeah I have a I listen I have
a new Dewalt cordless drill I can you
just oh that'll do it just drop me right
in and then hey let me ask you something
how much greater is the pressure than
the baking soda volcano I made in fourth
grade because that sucker spewed
everywhere and I gotta tell you it
ruined my mother's drapes I was grounded
for a weekly I can't believe that
indoors I did it outside
um in the garden on the grass and it
killed the grass and I was in loads of
trouble as well so yeah it's fun quick
question is there a common reason when
volcanoes go dormant in space is there a
Commons research shown in common
reason for that or does it vary
depending on the celestial body and
other factors or I don't know wait Paul
are you a patreon member
hang on a second I got five dollars
and put it in the piggy bank okay I
think it's a good question
um so basically in order for a a body to
be active in space it's got to be warm
we spoke about that in the last segment
and we were talking about how we've got
to have heat within a body to create
activity create movement of material
within that body whether it be rock or
methane or water whatever it is that
becomes that that magma and lava on that
of that particular body so if that
particular object cools down
um it loses its heat for some reason it
just primordial heat a lot of bodies
were just active because they had heat
from formation because they formed from
Big um kinetic um impacts in space and
that created heat and they just lose
that over time and they die they do all
the volcanic activity dies off and they
can no longer be active because they're
not warm enough but then we go somewhere
like Jupiter where we've got this push
and pull of the gravitational energy
those bodies can be active for forever
really because if they stay where they
are and Jupiter keeps going around the
Sun then they're going to keep being
active so there's really no no time
limit on that so can we say that Mars
has just simply cooled off yeah from its
formation and so it's smaller than Earth
it would cool faster and so now it's got
no action left exactly and the same with
the moon it's even smaller so it's just
cooled off quicker so Earth is sort of
this this really nice example it's not
too big that it became ridiculously
sized like Jupiter or something and and
it's just not even a rocky planet any
longer it's just big enough to to have
kept its primordial heat and it also
generates its own heat so it's kind of
that really nice sweet spot I've been
able to be active but not be too active
it's not too hot and it's not too cold
so it's kind of you know the perfect
Planet I think anyway I think it's a
nice place
says the geologist we're in a sweet spot
that gives us volcanoes earthquakes and
tsunamis thank you Natalie had a sweet
spot okay right imagine being at her
house hey there's going to be a
hurricane this weekend I can't wait
uh all right what else you got Paul keep
them coming yep we got Troy from
Virginia what are the current processes
of detecting life outside of Earth would
it be detecting radiation around an area
that could contain food for different
life forms or is it something else oh
that's really cool I love this topic um
so one of the ways that we first go out
into the solar system to look for life
is not to look for life itself it's a
look for the environments that could
host life so we want to look for
habitable environments now we think that
um includes liquid water because we we
think from what we know about Earth all
the environments we find in life and
where we think life started included
liquid water and heat so we go out to
all these places and this is why we're
sending the juice Mission which launched
us recently it's looking at some moons
around Jupiter that have those
environments they've got warm Interiors
they've got liquid water and and these
create what we call hydrothermal systems
which is what exists at the the bottom
of our oceans and we think life actually
started on Earth potentially at the
bottom of our oceans due and where the
heat is emanating from the earth and
it's interacting with salty liquid water
and creating nice environments from
microbes to thrive so that's where we're
going we're going to look for these
environments and then we're going to go
okay do these places host the right
ingredients for life and then we will
look for life because there's no point
Living For Life it's really hard to see
life because if it's microbial for
example we're not going to be able to
see that from orbit we're going to have
to land on that planet we're gonna have
to drill in we're going to have to delve
into an ocean to actually see microbes
drill baby drill wow
you know that's complicated of course if
there's dinosaurs roaming on these
places we'd see that from orbit fine but
but we don't expect
um to have dinosaurs roaming around so
we're looking for very probably small
life or it might have been life that
doesn't it's now died off so we'd be
looking for fossilized microbes which is
incredibly hard to find so initially
we're just going to look for
environments like we've been doing on
Mars we're looking for those kind of you
know saline and watery environments that
might have hosted life in the past and
that's the best place to start you don't
expect to see fossilized microbes
because they don't have like bones and
teeth right yeah
see
we have seen examples of where um
sometimes you know stuff without or
bones and everything has been preserved
and but it's incredibly it's really
uncommon you've got to have perfect
conditions of of deposition to kind of
cover that stuff over and preserve it
perfectly in that record so it's not
destroyed over time right yeah exactly I
mean you would need to be on the surface
of a planet to find that and you'd
probably want humans there to be looking
robots and you know they're going to go
and do a good job but you need you know
humans and and that aren't Superior
intelligence to help find these things
until AI becomes our overlords then
there are so perfect which is about a
week away
next week next week
it's happening why don't we just set out
some like like alien bait like a full
spectrum radiation banquet like it's
almost like a like a banquet on a
Carnival Cruise where just people eat so
much they fall asleep in their chair so
the aliens come they eat the radiation
banquet they fall asleep and then we
trap them and then we study them I mean
we we do send radio signals out into
space
um so this is assuming that aliens can
detect our radio signals and understand
what we're saying but we we have been
doing that and we've sent um messages
out on spacecraft over time you know to
go out there and just say look we're
here I don't know you know we're not
sure if that's a good idea because we
don't know if these aliens are friendly
or not you know in retrospect that feels
a little dangerous but yeah yeah yeah
yeah but yeah we do that and and you
know another way so when we're talking
about the solar system it's one thing
because we can get to these environments
we can send spacecraft and investigate
them but you then get to the exoplanet
so these are all the the objects around
other stars and other star systems so
far away we can't directly see them so
we're using a different type of science
then to try and detect what might be
going on initially we're just looking
for whether the planet is hot or cold
and how close it is to its its star
um because if it's too far away we don't
think it would be able to host life is
it too close it will be too hot so we're
looking for things that are kind of
within a zone that might be up to host
liquid water or definitely have activity
but that's like the next step a
Goldilocks on here yeah the Goldilocks
then is sort of being a little bit
disproven more recently because
um we're starting to now in our solar
system see environments you know way
away like Pluto for example not in the
Goldilocks zone but it's geologically
active and you know there is every
chance that life could have started
there um because it's got all kind of
the right conditions and for you know
very weird life to exist but it could be
there a new species of dog yeah who
knows it's labradoodles
it's a species of dog that cleans up
after itself please God please
wait so Natalie you mentioned you just
slipped by you mentioned it we did an
entire explainer on it but just for
those this might be their first time
hearing use the word a juice Mission
could you just oh yeah spend a mint just
a minute on that before we go to the
next question yeah so the G's Mission
just launched recently
um it's a European Space Agency Mission
and okay so the acronym is really forced
it's um Jupiter icy moons Explorer
um so you kind of have to think through
that one for how they got juice out of
it um but it does work in some way all
the letters are there within those words
anyway yeah Jay and Jupiter and I see
ice and e explorer that's not two sports
okay we'll give them that one we'll give
them a beatbox on that one all right
um but yeah it's not going to be
arriving at the Jupiter system until
2031 so I think you know this is one of
these crazy things about space missions
they set out and then it takes forever
to get anywhere in space and it's got to
do some slingshots of Earth and to gain
gravitational energy to get out to to
Jupiter but it's then going to be
looking at Europa Ganymede and Callisto
which are three of Jupiter's moons and
actually NASA are going to launch um
hopefully launch the Europa Clipper
Mission
um next year I believe which is actually
going to then get that's my
understanding next year it's getting
better ahead of um juice which is a bit
cheeky it's like gonna arriving a year
ahead even though it launches laser
absolutely everything's not a
competition well I think you know we're
sorry about 1776 you gotta let it go let
it go drop it oh my God
just to clarify if you do not launch
with sufficient energy to go straight
there then you need the gravity assist
through some you know multi-cushion pool
shot
uh in the solar system so it sounds from
what you said that our Clipper Mission
from NASA will be on a larger rocket and
it'll be able to go straight there and
not have to rely on gravity assist which
each time in the duration to the
destination exactly so yeah it just it
and it's also with the you know orbital
Dynamics it depends where the planets
are when everything launches and then
you know how far it is going to be to
get to places and whether you can go in
a straight line is the focus of the I
would imagine the focus of the two
missions different right I mean and it's
really really similar which is really
cool because they'll be complementary
um so Europa clip it is only looking at
Europa and but it's investigating the
signs for life and then um the uh juice
mission is looking at all of those moons
and investigating what their services
what the composition is getting more
information in detail just Imaging
surfaces we haven't got hugely
um detailed images of these places and
then measuring things like um particles
that come coming off of the surfaces and
discovering you know what's underneath
in their liquid oceans because they all
have liquidations they all I think they
all have more liquid water than we do
have on Earth that's my understanding
that's correct liquid content versus our
oceans right it's yes I think they have
is it is it Iowa that IO has a 100 mile
deep ocean or something like this that's
probably Europa is the really hot one so
that's the weird one all the others uh I
see that but yeah so they've got huge
oceans um I think it might be Ganymede
that's the biggest one and it's actually
bigger than Mercury like yeah it's a big
moon I understand that James Cameron's
going to Europa to see if there's
anything that's at the bottom of the
ocean that we can somehow make a movie
out of so that should be fine I'd watch
it but but I I want to start a movement
any life forms we find on Europa we
should call them Europeans okay yeah
there you go completely perfect that's
how we got to do that well we have an
explainer on that
um where if one of people want to do a
deep dive on it uh you can look it up on
our website so Paul give me one more
before I break you got it right here
this is uh Ian Diaz uh from North
Florida is it possible to get energy
from a planet's core and if it isn't
possible how could we hypothetically
achieve energy from a planet's core
I love that but let's let's do take that
break when we come back we're going to
find out what is the future of
geoengineering and how much energy does
earth have to give especially relative
to other sources such as oil or perhaps
even the sun when start talk continues
we're back for the third and final
segment of cosmic queries dark talk I
got Paul Mercurio with me as my co-host
and Natalie Starkey Natalie has two
books under her belt uh we've done shows
on each of those two books you can view
them out of our archives uh one of them
is called catching Stardust the study of
particles brought back to Earth from
space and just dust everywhere where it
matters when we think about life and my
favorite of those two sorry to pick one
of your children here
Fire and Ice it's got a way cooler title
I think I was gonna say can I just say
we need to make that a musical Fire and
Ice the musical
and then we'd have a volcano in Neil
like with Nathan Lane he comes singing
and dancing out of the volcano oh yeah
you need Nathan Lane if it's going to be
one of these so and uh Fire and Ice is
will be coming out in paperback soon
because that's the elevation of the two
books we we look forward to that and uh
and Paul just I I at the beginning at
the top I I forgot to tell people you
you're you're a comedian on The Late
Show with Stephen Colbert do you helped
write his jokes like how does this work
I I basically perform on the show he he
and I go back to the Daily Show together
I was right around The Daily Show I
worked on the cover report and I do a
mix of things on the uh Late Show I
think that's what we first met when I
was in there that's where we met yeah
I'm guessing on The Colbert Report yeah
I didn't know you were in The Green Room
and I came in and tried to steal some of
your snacks and you could that's not
going to happen yeah
and uh and yeah and I have a podcast
called inside out which you've been on
and Paul McCartney and Stephen Colbert
and a whole bunch of cool people so uh
yeah okay so just to be clear the title
of your podcast is inside out with Paul
McCartney yes it is yeah yeah I should I
should put my own name in there probably
would help right that's what it is okay
yeah and you got it but yeah all right
so let's pick up where we left off okay
we dangled the question and please
remind us of what that question was is
it possible to get energy from a
planet's core and if it's not how could
we hypothetically uh do that achievement
plus Natalie if the core is really
really hot then there surely places
between the Surface and the core that
are not as hot where you don't have to
dig as deep and you could in principle
still get energy from it isn't that
right yeah so I mean the core of the
planet is incredibly hot I think it
might be hotter than the surface of the
Sun most of this heat in our core is
left over from four and a half billion
years ago when the planet formed and
you've got all those impacts happening
in space that builds up the planets and
that kinetic energy was turned into heat
which was stored within that metal core
okay so you've got a lot of what we call
primordial heat in there but then you've
got this mantle of rock that sits around
there and actually that generates heat
all the time because we've got lots of
radioactive elements sitting within the
Rock and that decay over time and
release little bits of heat which when
you've got a huge amount of rock that
does that creates a huge amount of heat
for our planet so we've got that initial
heat and then we've got the heat we're
always making and that's about 50 50 in
terms of the heat that our planet gives
out now because of physics he always
wants to move from somewhere hot to
somewhere cold which is space so it
moves from the inside out and it keeps
our planet active and it creates
volcanoes and earthquakes
um but it also gives us our liquid water
and it can create energy for us so you
know if we go to somewhere like Iceland
use all their electricity comes from
geothermal energy
um and and they actually Heat their
roads um using just the heat from the
earth because it's very very cold in
Iceland and they have very icy roads so
they just they just heat them because
they've got all this excess energy which
they don't have to generate that's the
most badass thing I've ever read about
that's awesome so they don't have snow
shovels or they'll have to Salt the road
they do in some places
um but in particularly in Reykjavik
because it's quite um you know it's not
a huge population in Iceland but lot of
people do live in the capital city and
you know they can just do that they hold
this excess heat so they can just heat
it and interesting point is that they
used to be run on fossil fuels and they
just made a determined effort to for
this shift it's one of the more
brilliant sort of uh scientifically
literate energy stories in the world
yeah and they can do that because they
they're a volcanically active place they
sit on the Mid-Atlantic Ridge but they
also have a hot spot underneath um
Iceland which is just this kind of warm
area of the mantle um that produces
excess um heat and excess volcanoes
you've got the same in Hawaii
um it's it's a hot spot volcano but you
can you don't need to be near a plate
boundary where you create volcanoes or
near a hot spots and necessarily create
geothermal energy you actually just need
to drill down and not even very deep if
you drill down a kilometer and you get a
25 degree increase in temperatures now
you don't even need that much increase
to generate a little bit of heat I don't
know in in the US if you have like air
source heat pumps for your houses we
have they're quite common here now so we
don't even know what that is I've never
you're creating heat for your house
you were lying my no I I will show you a
picture right now it works at 30 listen
to me I know something about science
here focus at 35
degrees or above this is a heat pump so
I don't use so much oil in my furnace
and it it's 35 degrees or above there's
enough moisture in the air it's a
reverse process so it's like it's an air
conditioning condenser that reverses its
process it takes from the cold the
moisture goes through and it turns it
into heat I am done I finally said
something that I know what I'm talking
about all right it's good
we've saved a ton of money in all
seriousness on our house we've saved a
ton of money on oil with this yeah it's
becoming very common in the UK that
we're actually switching over to these
little new build houses anyways that's
kind of a tangent but like basically we
don't need a ton of um heat to actually
create enough to to heat houses heat hot
water in other words you don't need to
dig to the core of a planet to gain
access to the energy that remains within
the planet itself yeah exactly so we
yeah and we need to do that more um you
know if we want to do that it is
environmentally we've got to question it
a little bit because we've got to dig
into our planet and we've got to lay
pipes but you know then we wouldn't
require fossil fuels which would be
great um but yeah it's just one form of
renewable energy which we're not really
using but Iceland have done it great I
think areas of New Zealand do it and
because they have a nice high heat flow
as well
um but yeah definitely we take heat from
our planet all the time very cool why
don't we harness the energy that we
expect to get to the center of a Salted
Caramel Core pint of Ben and Jerry's ice
cream because
you're working toward that core
we'll get top people working on that
ball
this is from William drilling down uh to
Lake Bostock in our Antarctica has been
cited as an as an analog for exploring
ice moons like Europa can you tell us
what was learned from Boston I love that
so what is Lake vostok Natalie so the
really cool thing about these
environments on Earth uh like Lake
vostok and there's some other areas in
Antarctica we can look at is that um
you've got these bodies of water that
have remained sort of pristine since
they formed so you've been capped off
with ice and you've got this um this
water that's just stayed there the same
and hasn't had any human interactions
um in all the years it's been there and
this is very similar to you know the
places we look at like Europa organymede
or anywhere else where we've got these
liquid oceans with this this ice capping
it not only just not no human
interaction nothing has reached it right
no other part of the biosphere has
touched it right so these have been like
so if something's gonna happen it's all
up to itself right exactly
isn't it like 16 million years ago it
was believed to have been sealed off
like that long ago or even longer
certainly on an evolutionary time scale
I don't remember exactly how how long
these have been capped off but that's
the I just the only point of this is
it's it's like an analog right is that
what would you say yeah so we need
analogs because it's incredibly hard to
go out and actually investigate these
places in space and we spoke about that
already
um in this episode you know it's we got
to send spacecraft is expensive it takes
years to get these missions out there
and plan them so actually if we can look
at a similar environment on our own
planets and compare it with those
environments we think exist in space
then we can do a lot of the work before
we even have to go out there and
investigate what's there so they become
like a little comparative
um planetology experiment um and and it
just gives scientists a really easy way
to do their work although it's still
relatively hard to get to Antarctica but
we can actually do that science before
we go to Europa and we can make all the
mistakes here and then figure out what
we need to do in space with a very
limited equipment have they found weird
life forms do we know what do we know so
what we know about so we find lots of
strange environments on Earth some of
the strangest environments are at the
bottom of our oceans um where you find
organisms living that just shouldn't be
able to survive there's no light and
it's incredibly dark and high pressure
is very cold and and these kind of
environments are where we find microbes
that we call extremophiles they like
extreme environments um so humans and
other animals that we see on the surface
of the Earth couldn't survive down there
um but there are organisms that have
adapted to those environments and and
Thrive there's a whole you know a whole
colony of animals and bugs and things
down there which um we just weren't
expecting to find So Gone is this
constant this darwinian concept of the
room temperature tide pool yeah that's
where you need the like I mean this it
blows it right up blows it completely
open yeah in fact life probably we think
most likely started in one of these very
extreme environments and so we've kind
of developed to now think that we live
in a very you know we can't stand
extreme temperatures we humans are a bit
rubbish in that respect so Paul did you
just call us whip-ass creatures
I think she did I think she did no I did
not shave for this I don't you know I
can I just ask you talked about the lake
Voss like being an analog but is is it
isn't it limited in some ways because
you can only extrapolate so much because
the host bodies are different right
Earth is a different Celestial body than
say Europa so you there's only so much
you can glean yeah from that animal and
that's like with any science we do that
we have to start with a set of
assumptions and and we always know
there's going to be you know limits to
the experiment and and that would be one
of the limits it's not the same place
but it's it's pretty close in in some
respects it's close enough that we can
test out some of these theories um
before we go out into space hey we don't
do close enough in America right we do
it right or we don't do it at all
there you go do we want to go another
one more time we got time a couple more
yeah yeah let's do it this is Chase uh
greetings Dr Tyson and Dr Starkey Chase
from Indianapolis here uh my question is
could you pump as much water in the
ocean as is to be added per year by the
melting ice and then put it in a rocket
and ship it to Mars
oh so that we don't have so that in the
climate change we don't flood the
coastal city thus thus saving coastal
cities and accelerating Mars projects
wow because I bet the cost of picking up
cities and moving them Inland 50 miles
is probably more than shipping water to
Mars can we just over we're overthinking
it can we just get 500 million jugs of
Poland Spring delivered to another
planet it's probably got it in bulk
discount at Costco you create you
brilliant scientists you're always
overthinking things yeah that's true
that's true just ship it all out so I
think the first part of that question I
have no idea but the second part is
going to be the main issue I think I'm
sure someone who pumps water might
understand the first part a bit more but
the second part is going to be an issue
anyway because to launch bulk into space
is the most expensive thing so this is
why when we design space missions we
make everything very small and light the
instruments we send
um usually are not very large you know
some of them are literally the size of a
shoebox obviously some spacecraft are
much larger but they're made to be light
because um it's just very expensive the
more rocket fuel you'll need to launch
some Mass into space the more rocket
fuel you'll need because you've got them
more rocket fuel and it just is
exponential so you want to keep
everything light so launching water into
space is never going to be a good idea
we we have to do it but actually we
limit it so on the International Space
Station they recycle their urine because
they don't have an unlimited supply of
water if we go to the moon and Mars like
we're planning and to send humans out
and create bases out there they're going
to need to find ways to generate their
own water either from rocks on the
surface of the planet and the dust or
from a passing Comet or asteroid we
might mine it for water that's actually
going to be much more efficient than
trying to launch the stuff off our own
Planet so that is a massive problem so
Paul I think the answer is no yeah sorry
Chase that's a big no but that's a total
no and last I heard the cost to launch a
pound of anything in a payload is
somewhere between five and ten thousand
dollars so the the rate which the ice is
melting
per pound times ten thousand dollar you
know that's just it would be prohibitive
calculation what did it cost uh visas to
launch William Shatner
let's get the calculator
can we uh uh you want to do another
question yeah yeah let's go this is
Kayla Hunter hey guys uh what would
happen if a volcano erupted on the moon
where the gravity is at Point 16 G with
the lava float in the air or up and out
into space
very cool so let me let me sharpen that
question so the thrust of ejections from
volcanoes might might they be fast
enough to achieve escape velocity for
the moon or will it just be like a
volcano in slow motion where things go
up and fall down slowly
throw out material in plumes and some of
that material ends up making Saturn's
e-ring so one of the Rings I think is
the second one in um on that goes around
Saturn the material for that ring comes
from enceladus's volcano so it did
achieve escape velocity it did yes okay
now
um on the moon we've had loads of
volcanoes uh but about three billion
years ago they all sort of stopped now
we had usually um they were quite
basaltic in composition so this is the
same kind of uh volcanoes as we get in
Iceland and Hawaii very um flowy they're
they're very not very viscous
um so they don't have a lot of energy to
explode out and they just kind of flow
over the surface is that an official
word flowy is that Chloe
that's the name that's the name of her
Labradoodle
the one she the one she's breeding on
the planet Pluto okay yeah exactly right
it's part part of that whole creepy
breeding process she has going on in her
basement in the basement yeah okay I
like Crepes and some of the eruptions on
the moon were more explosive
towards the end of
um stuff was less flowy let's say and uh
and actually became much more explosive
um and we got um fire fountains so I
don't even remember there's been quite a
few fire Fountain eruptions on Earth in
the last few years
um La Palma had some I think a couple of
years ago La Palma of the Canary Islands
yeah yeah so I don't know if you
remember it was all over the news 2021
um huge fire Fountain eruptions and that
actually would have happened
um on the moon back in the day about
three billion years ago so but again
they the Magma's too heavy it's too
dense in order to kind of escape the
Moon Moon surface but um generally it
all just rained back down so yeah in
general it won't be out floating around
in space is it different for cryo
volcanoes is it different for something
that's sort of emitting sort of ice and
yeah definitely so gases will definitely
you know be able to escape much more
easily because they're lighter
um but it really depends on it just
depends on the individual body and how
much gravity it has But ultimately it's
going to be pretty hard for most stuff
to Escape unless it's it's very
explosive like we find an Enceladus or
something well plus the moon has a
stronger gravity anyway than probably
many of those other moons armor is one
of the bigger moons in the whole solar
system we got a badass moon for for how
small Earth is right so yeah our moon
can take your move
[Laughter]
outside
me in the parking lot behind the school
man
uh so I think that's all the time we
have for questions but I want to get
some a final Reflection from you Natalie
uh much of what you describe in the
questions that related to life
um it sounds like we're looking for Life
as We Know It
and is it in the end wouldn't that be
highly restrictive
um Ken is there a way to look for Life
As We Don't Know It
the thing is we still know that
everything in the solar system and the
universe has to adhere to the laws of
physics and chemistry as we understand
them so it always doesn't make sense to
start looking for life in some other
element reform that you know doesn't
make any sense for the way that we
understand science but it doesn't mean
that another solvent like methane or
something couldn't actually host life so
we are looking not just at places that
have liquid water but for example Titan
which is a moon of Saturn we're looking
at that because it has water but it's
also got a methane cycle so instead of a
hydrological cycle it's got um rivers
and and Rain of methane and that comes
and goes and it has clouds that form so
it's this active environment but it
isn't water necessarily that we think
the life could be surviving on but this
is all organic based stuff so again it's
all liquid water might be an unnecessary
assumption maybe it's just liquid of
some yes
liquid to be able to move things around
so um you know
organic material needs to be able to
move and and find other bits of organic
material and to create you know the
basic forms of life so without liquid
you're going to really struggle and but
even in a really icy environment there's
always going to be some liquid at like
you know the edges of glaciers or
whatever it might be so there's always
the potential um but we don't
necessarily need water we don't think
but we know that water works because
we've seen it happen here so that's
where we're initially looking but yeah
you know there could be
life based on other forms of things that
we don't currently understand but it
doesn't make sense to go and look for
that because we need to start with what
we know and and then work out from there
because there's too many you know it
would just be crazy to start looking for
things we won't wouldn't know how to
recognize it or detect it if it didn't
look like stuff that we understand okay
so Paul I think she's just trying to
prevent people from investigating her
basement there exactly absolutely that's
all the time we have Natalie it's been
Delight to have you back uh I forgot how
much we missed you uh over covid and
we're going to reach for you again
because the solar system is a
never-ending uh playground uh of space
probes and new hypotheses and the search
for life so thanks for being a guest
once again on start talking thanks for
having me all right Paul we'll look for
you on the on The Late Show with Stephen
Colbert thank you this has been another
episode of StarTalk Cosmic queries Neil
deGrasse Tyson here as always
looking up
[Music]